(buzzing)
- Nick what'd you do that for?
- Do what?
- You killed the mozzy.
- Yeah?
- Dude that thing probably
has a family, you know?
- Where you going?
- [Voiceover] I'm burying it!
- Hey, Ten, can you do me a huge favor,
and cover my Sunday shift?
I've just got a thing on.
- Oh, it's kind of my friends wedding.
- It just would mean a whole lot to me,
it'd be a huge favor, I'd owe you one.
- Okay, sure.
- Oh, awesome, you are the best, thanks.
- No worries.
- Hey, Nick, what are you doing?
- I got a date tonight,
I'm gonna try something new with my hair.
How's it looking so far?
- It looks great.
- Yeah? Sweet, thanks man.
- Hey Jemima, happy birthday!
- Ten it was my birthday last week.
You didn't get me anything.
- I got you this.
- Oh.
- Here you go.
- Cool.
- And, surprise.
- Aw.
- Hey Eli, nice shirt.
- What's that supposed to mean?
- No, I'm being serious, I
actually like your shirt.
- Alright.
What's wrong with the world today?
- Kay so this is Lane, that's Allen,
Moxy, Rob, and uhm, Elly?
- It's Eli.
- Oh, Eli, sorry mate.
- No one understands.
- I do.
It's gonna be okay.